How do you turn an airplane? Do you turn
it like a car? I mean, the yolk does
kind of turn like that, doesn't it? In
this video, I'm going to explain all
that because if you want to be a pilot,
then you need to understand how an
airplane turns.
[groaning]
Welcome to Free Pilot Training. I'm
Josh. This is the episode you've all
been waiting for because today I'm going
to explain how an airplane turns. Up
until this point, you've probably just
been flying in a straight line. So,
we're going to fix that today. Now, take
it easy. I'm just giving you a hard
time. I'm sure you do know a little bit
about how an airplane turns. But there's
actually quite a bit more to it than you
might think if you're new to all this.
And a lot of your flight training is
actually going to be building on this
very topic. So, let's get started by
taking a look at the top of this
airplane. When you look at a
two-dimensional picture of an airplane
like this, your first inclination might
lead you to believe that we turn an
airplane by yawing the aircraft one way
or another. But this is actually not the
case. Instead, we have to bank or roll
the airplane along its longitudinal axis
to get it to turn. And if you remember
from one of our last lessons, we do this
by rotating the yolk left or right
depending on which direction we want to
go. Keep in mind if you have a stick
instead of a yolk, moving the stick left
and right does the same thing as
rotating the yolk. Now, you may remember
that our ailerons are tied together and
they're connected in such a way that
when we raise one aileron, the other
aileron lowers. And if you're wondering
why my weird little hands have my thumb
sticking up, this is an easy way to
remember which aileron comes up when you
rotate the yolk. All you have to do is
remember thumbs up, ailerons up. Anyway,
this is important because anytime we
lower an aileron, we increase the camber
of that wing. And this means that this
wing now creates more lift while the
aileron on the other side comes up and
creates less lift. This in turn rolls
the aircraft whichever direction you
want to go. If you're like me, you're
probably more confused than when we
started. How could rolling the airplane
cause it to turn? Wouldn't we just
continue to fly straight ahead at this
weird caned angle? Not much gets past
you, does it? The truth is rolling the
airplane by itself won't actually make
your airplane turn. Something else needs
to happen when you bank the aircraft if
you want it to turn. And this is where
things start to get a little tricky to
understand. When an airplane is in
straight and level flight, the lift that
your wings produce basically goes
straight up. And when an aircraft is in
a level attitude like this, we call this
vertical lift because it's literally
going straight up. But if we roll the
airplane one way or another, some of
that lift is moved laterally. Now, it's
important to remember that some of that
lift is still going straight up. If it
wasn't, the airplane would literally
fall out of the sky. But then the rest
of this lift has been transferred
laterally along the horizontal axis of
the aircraft. And this is what we call
the horizontal component of lift. And
this horizontal component of lift is
actually what's responsible for turning
our airplane. And by the way, if you're
taking notes, I want you to write that
down. The horizontal component of lift
is how we get an airplane to turn. But
now I want you to think about something.
What do you think will happen to our
vertical lift if we trade some of it for
horizontal lift by rolling the airplane?
Will this vertical lift increase or
decrease? Well, we took some of it to
turn it into horizontal lift. So that
vertical lift will decrease, won't it?
So if we want to keep our aircraft from
descending, we need to do something. We
need to increase the lift that our wings
are producing. And remember, we've got
two tools we can use to do that. We can
either increase our air speed or we can
increase our angle of attack by pulling
back on the yolk. Now, the easiest thing
to do is to pull back on the yolk. And
this does three things. First, it
increases the vertical lift that our
wings are producing because if we didn't
do that, then the airplane would descend
because there's less vertical lift now
that we're tilted to the side. Second,
it increases the horizontal component of
lift. And this is important because when
we traded this vertical lift for
horizontal lift, we didn't really create
that much horizontal lift by rolling the
airplane. We need to keep some of that
vertical lift so the airplane doesn't
fall out of the sky. And to keep us from
descending, we need to pull back on the
yolk to bring that vertical lift back up
where it was before we started the turn.
And when we do this, this also increases
our horizontal lift, which turns the
airplane in the direction that the
aircraft is banked. Once again, this is
important to remember. You need to roll
and pull to get the airplane to turn
properly without descending. Now,
there's one more thing that pulling back
on the yolk does. Not only does this
increase our vertical and horizontal
lift, it also increases the force of
inertia acting on the weight of our
airplane. We call this our load factor.
We'll be discussing this more in the
next lesson. But this is super important
to know because load factor actually
increases exponentially the more we bank
the airplane. And the amount you need to
pull back on the yolk to keep it from
descending is directly related to this
force. In the next lesson, we're going
to be discussing this in a lot more
detail. There's quite a bit you need to
know about load factor, and I want to
give it its own lesson because extreme
load factors can cause you to damage the
airplane or even stall the aircraft well
before normal stall speed. Hey, thanks
for joining me today on Free Pilot
Training. If you enjoyed this video,
please smash that like button for me. It
helps the algorithm or something like
that. If you're enjoying this series,
I've got something totally free for you
guys. This is my free private pilot
[music] ground course on an interactive
PDF. And what you'll find here is the
videos you already love from free pilot
training along [music] with some extra
quizzes and stuff. And that makes it a
little bit easier to follow than just a
playlist. And that's available over on
free pilotraining.net. Thanks for
watching. See you.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.